[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur salis welt heute
kommt ein sehr gefragtes rezept ich
werde nämlich man zu machen mantels sind
kleine teigtaschen gefüllt mit
hackfleisch oder auch mit linsen oder
auch kartoffeln das ganze gibt's in der
türkei gibt es aber auch in vielen
anderen ländern aus russland kenne ich
seh oder auch aus der afghanischen küche
vielleicht kennt ihr ja noch weitere
länder wo es eben auch man zugibt ich
denke vom grundgedanken her gibt sie
wahrscheinlich in jedem land nur sind
sie anders geformt anders gefühlt und
sehen einfach ein bisschen anders aus
ich werde jetzt zuerst mal den teig
herstellen dafür brauche ich also ich
mache eine große menge 1700 gramm mehl
ich habe jetzt hier ein dinkelmehl das
630 er 750 gramm warmes wasser 3 1 2
teelöffel salz und 30 gramm sonnenblumen
er hat das sind die grundzutaten und ich
mache jetzt eine große menge denn manche
eignen sich hervorragend zum einfrieren
und ich denke mir dann immer wenn man
sich schon die arbeit macht so macht man
gleich eine große menge und habe direkt
was auf vorrat
ihr könnt jetzt den teig mit der hand
vernähten oder mit der küchenmaschine
ich mache das jetzt hier ganz einfach in
der küchenmaschine gebe jetzt erst mal
nur zwei drittel mehr rein dann kommt
ihr das wasser das so die angeblich rein
ich muss sagen meine mama mit der hammel
früher oft man so zusammen gemacht aber
so in den letzten jahren irgendwie nicht
mehr wahrscheinlich weil es einfach viel
arbeit ist und als ich noch zu hause
gewohnt habe haben wir sie halt immer
schön zusammen geformt und jetzt ja
jetzt mach ich mal geht es meiner mama
das ist sollte man als gute tochter
und jetzt den teig schön verkneten ich
gebe dann einfach nach und nach noch das
restliche mehl dazu es sollte ein fester
teig seien nicht so weit also nicht wie
hefeteig aber auch nicht so hart wie
nudelteig also so eine gesunde zwischen
mischung
[Musik]
wie seine zutaten rutsche
und je nach milchsorte kann sein dass
ihr das ganze milch braucht oder ein
bisschen weniger bei dinkel braucht man
eher etwas weniger weil dinkel einfach
mehr flüssigkeit aufzieht weizenmehl
hätte ich jetzt wahrscheinlich komplett
aufgebraucht
aber ich glaube ich fast immer kommt ist
schon schon noch weich aber dafür auch
nicht so hart werden
ich glaube noch ein esslöffel gebe ich
dazu nur zwei und lasst ihn jetzt etwa
fünf bis zehn minuten kneten bis sie
schön geschmeidig und wenn ihr das per
hand macht ist ein bisschen anstrengend
bei der großen menge
jetzt ist der teig perfekt gott ist es
viel zeit
jetzt lasse stehen ein bisschen ruhe
einfach hier in einer schüssel schön
abdecken und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich mich schon mal um die füllung
kümmern ich mache es jetzt ganz
traditionell mit einer hackfleisch
füllung und werde jetzt gleich hier für
meinen hackfleisch selber machen und die
füllung besteht auch mal aus zwei
zutaten nämlich hackfleisch und eine
zwiebel und da kommen dann auch gewürze
dazu
für die füllung seien kleinere ich 750
gramm rindfleisch das sollte etwas mager
sein und danach kann ich direkt die
zwiebel die habe ich bereits geschält
und in feine stücke geschnitten
auch direkt durch den fleischwolf geben
so wird sie extra klein und jetzt kommen
da einfach noch die gewürze dazu ich
nehme einen teelöffel salz einen halben
teelöffel pfeffer und eine prise chili
[Musik]
jetzt einfach alles gut vermischen
ich sage ich jetzt mal zuerst die
traditionelle art und weise wie man man
zur herstellt und zwar könnt ihr euch
jetzt aus dem teig so ungefähr acht bis
zehn portionen machen den besten so eine
kugel formen und den übrigen teil immer
schön abdecken damit er einfach nicht
austrocknet und jetzt nehmt ihr euch
etwas nähe und öffnet den teig also holt
ihn aus
und das macht man eigentlich ganz
traditionell mit sondern opfer erfordert
ein bisschen übung und da muss ich auch
dazu sagen das sind normale ausrollt
starb da einfach nicht ausreicht denn
der teig sollte schon recht dünn werden
also erst mal so ein bisschen öffnen
jetzt könnt ihr praktisch diesen stab
nehmen den teig auf wickeln und dann mit
den händen öffnen und dann wird er immer
jemand ich nur darauf achten dass nicht
zu viel mehl verwendet wird denn ich
muss heute teigtaschen gleich schließen
und zudem darf der teig auch nicht sein
als er so nudel stärke so ein millimeter
ungefähr bis jetzt habe ich ihn
zerrissen
ich nehme jetzt kurz von tabak motto
runter denn ich werde jetzt schneiden
und manche ist eigentlich so ein
gesellschafts ding also mal macht im
prinzip mit der ganzen familie mit den
kindern mit dem ehemann mit der mama mit
der schwester und dann hat auch wirklich
die ganze familie aus davon jetzt nehmt
ihr euch entweder ein messer oder einer
pizza rat ich habe jetzt mal ein
bisschen glück denn damit kann ich fünf
linien auf einmal zum schneiden so zu
sagen ich mache das ganze jetzt drei
zentimeter breit und in chrysler in der
türkei wo man da eben herkommt da ist es
wirklich so dass interessent 21 oder 41
ich bin mir gerade unsicher aber 21 oder
41 mahnte auf einen esslöffel passen ja
auf einen esslöffel die sind ja masala
die sind wirklich so klein und ok das
mache ich nicht ich mache sie wirklich 3
x 13 cm groß und bis es schon klein aber
ihr könnt es auch gerne größer oder
kleiner hat so bereiten
meine cousine hat die früher immer mit
dem lineal ausgemessen
damit jeder streifen rock es liegt in
der familie
damit gleich
[Musik]
du denkst gerade lohnt sich der aufwand
ich sage dir der aufwand lohnt sich aber
das ist ja hier die traditionelle art
und weise ich zeigt ihr euch kurz aber
ich werde nach diesem video nie wieder
machen denn ich zeige euch gleich eine
einfache variante die viel schneller
geht und genauso gut schmeckt die
vielleicht nicht die typische optik hat
aber die ich als zweifach mama und voll
berufstätige jederzeit zubereiten kann
aber ich wollte euch diese methode
trotzdem zeigen nicht das einer
behauptet ich kann das nicht
[Musik]
nehmt ihr euch so ein kleines quadrat
zwischen die finger und bleibt sozusagen
die vier ecken so zusammen dass in der
mitte ist eine kreuzung entsteht so das
macht jetzt mit allen mit dem kompletten
restlichen teig und ich sag dann immer
wer nicht mitgeholfen hat die mannschaft
zu formen das ja auch nicht essen
also man muss im prinzip darauf achten
dass außen ein bisschen mehlig ist damit
ich finger nicht dran geben und ihnen
sollte er halt schon ein bisserl
zusammenkleben und wenn wir uns perfekt
macht hat man mit einem drucker
sozusagen erledigt ich gebe sie hier
noch in so ein blech mit bisschen mehl
und wie gesagt kann man die super
vorbereiten und dann eben auch
einfrieren
entweder kann man sie vor backen so dass
er einfach da nicht merkt leben und dann
einfrieren oder man lässt sie einfach
nebeneinander schönen einfrieren und
packte dann in der tüte zum beispiel
oder in ein gefäß aber ist schon extrem
viel arbeit also dass einige mache ich
jetzt fertig und zeig ich euch gleich
noch eine variante die einfacher geht
man könnte auch dreiecke formen aber das
ist so die traditionelle
[Musik]
option eins ist geschafft ich habe mir
da jetzt auch zwei fleißige helferlein
dazu geholte einigen und sarah haben
beide den türkisch test bestanden
allerdings herzlich nur der grund jetzt
zeige ich aber noch eine methode die
wirklich einfacher ist denn ich muss
sagen ich mag zwar die traditionelle
form aber ich persönlich habe nicht die
zeit dazu dass die jetzt hier einfach
ein bisschen antrocknen das ist okay
also ihr könnt jetzt entweder weiterhin
mit dem oktober praktisch oder mit einem
ausbaustopp ausrollen oder ihr nehmt
gleich noch die nudelmaschine dazu und
so mache ich das jetzt aber ich habe es
einmal ein bisschen vor den übrigen teig
wieder schön abdecken
[Musik]
das ist nämlich mein nudelholz also
meine nudel walze und das ist so eine
extragroße die standard die wir ungefähr
so ist auch okay aber ich möchte da habe
ich falls jetzt noch ein bisschen wie
beim nudelteig damit ich die schöne
volle breite ausnutzen kann
und wenn geraten strangen bekomme dann
einfach immer dünner einstellen
[Musik]
also ich bin jetzt hier bis stufe 5
gegen das reicht dann muss man es
wickelt machen
und jetzt könnt ihr die entweder wie
gewohnt fein schneiden und dann zu
bereiten wie gerade eben wenn ihr sagt
ihr wollt die traditionelle form oder er
macht jetzt einfach so nehmt euch die
hackfleisch masse und platziert sich
hier zu einem langen strang
da oben nun mal der gleiche strang
ist hier einmal umwickeln also wie so
eine kleine rolle
und dann wirklich es noch einmal so weit
dass praktischer teil nochmal außen rum
geht und jetzt schneidet ihr euch
einfach eure kleine matte zu die sehen
dann aus wieso keine rolle finde ich
auch ganz süß und ich würde mal
behaupten sie schmecken genauso gut
experten würden vielleicht sagen ob es
schmeckt schon ein bisschen anders aber
ich mach das so weil es wirklich zeit
sparend ist sowas kann man auch wenn ich
mir im alltag dann schön unterbringen
amicom teig herstellen kurz ausrollen
wieder maschine kommt das geht schon
schneller kurz der vag fleisch gemacht
das ist schon was was ich machen würde
für die mittagspause für so nach der
schule habe es auch wenn ich aber ist es
immerhin so vereinfacht und für
diejenigen die jetzt sagen alles zuviel
arbeit ihr könnt ja meinen songs jetzt
an das zu machen da gibt es auch schon
ein rezept auf dem kanal
da mach ich nämlich daraus einfach so
große nudeln schmecken
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt auch diese portion fertig
ich habe aber noch einiges an zeit übrig
was ich bin noch nicht komplett fertig
aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie man
sie zubereitet wie gesagt wenn ihr sie
ein frieden wollt so einfrieren und wenn
sie gefroren sind könnte sich dann schön
verpacken
wenn ihr sie jetzt so direkt in eine
schüssel verpackten verkleben sie
einfach entweder antrocknen vorher im
backofen oder eben anfrieren und dann
verpacken jetzt habe ich hier einen
großen topf da kommt salehs mit rein und
das salz immer dann erst dazu geben wenn
das wasser schon koch damit ihr einfach
eure kochtöpfen ich beschädigt denn das
salz landet unten am boden und kann dann
einfach mit der zeit so kleine löcher
auch verursachen
deswegen wirklich immer erst wenn sich
das salz auflösen kann also wenn das
wasser heiß ist oder kommt dann habe ich
hier noch ein kleines quäntchen und zwar
kann ich da schon mal ein bisschen
butter dazugeben
für die mutter sophie und ist das wasser
hier so weit ist so weiß es gleich so
weit ist
jetzt kann ich hier meine mum zu kochen
und die brauchen so ungefähr 15 bis 20
minuten
je nachdem wie groß es sind je nachdem
wie dick eben auch der teig ist sie
schwimmen dann einfach oben wenn sie
fertig sind
das dauert jetzt ein bisschen und ich
kenne da zwischenzeit schon mal die soße
zubereiten nämlich joghurt und
dreieinhalb prozentigen und den wird
sich mit salz pfeffer und knoblauch
ok es ein riesenei war so richtig
typisch türkisch schließlich sagen meine
mama hat er hatte auch immer so fünf
kilo joghurt im kühlschrank
die knoblauchzehe einfach dazu pressen
oder dazu treiben und die werden einfach
traditionell mit joghurt gegessen so
richtig lecker ich hast du jemals manche
gegessen dann darfst du gleich probieren
ganz fertig ist okay aber ich muss sagen
so mit joghurt ist liebt ja bei mir
gibt's dazu allem joghurt aber ich
glaube das nicht so der typische
europäische geschmacks sondern wirklich
er türkisch angehaucht dann gebe ich
noch ein bisschen minister dazu wird im
herbst und da drüben zur butter dem ich
tomatenmark
jetzt ein bisschen mit anbraten
nicht so hoch stellen damit die butter
nicht verbrenne nichts mit dem
tomatenmark und da gibt es auch
unterschiede da kann man jetzt entweder
tomatenmark nehmen oder man nimmt
einfach paprikapulver das mag ich auch
sehr gerne aber mit tomatenmark ist auch
lecker also wählen ich aber entscheiden
müsste ich will es heute ein bisschen
suppiger lassen deswegen habe ich das
tomatenmark genommen weil ich es gleich
mit bisschen von dem wasser servieren
aber ich mag es auch gern wenn man
paprikapulver nimmt und das war so
drüber lehrt vielleicht mache ich noch
dazu wenn die masse dann soweit sind
also normalerweise kocht meine große
portion klappt das jetzt hier für 52 uhr
und wenn man eine große patient kann man
im prinzip jetzt dieses diese tomaten
butter hier mit rein geben
man kann so ein bisschen sub ich lassen
also mit soße oder mannschaft eben
komplett ab ich gebe es jetzt hier
allerdings in den kleinen topf denn da
habe ich jetzt auf den vorteil dass die
manche nicht abkühlen
sie bleiben einfach schön warm ich gebe
aber noch die soße dazu
ich finds frau hübsch wenn man das dann
so sehr wird und sie sind einfach nicht
so schnell kalt weil wir metzingen
kalten joghurt dazu gibt dann finde ich
es oft relativ schnell kalt auch zu kalt
aber so
hmm schön warm
ich mache jetzt noch eine schöne portion
für dich hast damit du gleich probieren
kannst du kriegst auch gleich eine große
portion okay der kleine jungs krieg
gleich eine große portion aber zuerst
mal die foto portion und danach ist eine
große portion also hier wird jeder sagt
dass er wird nicht verhungern nicht dass
es gleich heißt die politik geizige gibt
dem arm und joshua ist lang präsentieren
zwar nehme jetzt schon so aus ein
bisschen
ja sonst auch sonst ich jetzt noch
nichts bekommen bei uns aber du kriegst
gleich versprochen
und wer will kann zum beispiel noch
petersilie darüber geben aber ich finde
so pur schmeckt einfach am besten
einfach nur mit joghurt
ok kaum hat die kamera aufs stativ und
kein problem ich bin echt gespannt so
ich bin sehr gespannt
ich bin auch sehr ich als das was ich
noch darüber machen warte ich schöpfe
daraus die letzten die handgemachten dem
sind also behandelt werden da hat jedes
einzelne meinen respekt meine wilde um
eine anerkennung dass auch meine respekt
ihr sohn arthur machen
also ich glaube wenn dann würde ich die
rolle die schnellere varianten sie waren
ja vielleicht werde ich ja auch
maultaschen machen
das antwortete weil sie sind zwar groß
aber ich bin schon die müssen schon so
nächsten schon so dass laien sein was
ist sieht hammer aus genau uns jetzt
noch eine prise schilling
das passt gut und jetzt probier mal wir
auch mal einen löffel um zu gucken ob so
schmeckt wie ich es mir gewünscht habe
ein bisschen aber richtig gut
lohnt sich der aufwand auf jeden fall
also die kombination mit diesem tomaten
bisschen chili joghurt das habe ich je
kennengelernt wo ich wurde in der türkei
war ja also hatten wir immer echt gut
gefallen und somit mit viel ihr wort und
ich bin schockiert dass es noch nicht
gegessen hast denn die rad doch schon
den kreis elbe-elster ist auch hier
haben wir die großen töpfe gedreht kann
ich übrigens sehr empfehlen das video
vor
die herstellung von einem großen töpfen
kommen die probieren doch die hier
stimmt doch gar nicht getesteten ja
deswegen ich bin voll steht also würde
ich nach kreis hätte reisen ich selbst
war mache dort haben wir das essen wird
[Musik]
ja okay vielleicht ja vielleicht wer
weiß dass wir haben nicht viel gegessen
okay das problem mir noch die anderen
die rollen müssen jetzt ruhig schmecken
auch wunderbar den film bei den anderen
hat man so verschiedenen konsistenzen
mein rand und mitte ich find die also
also diese taschen
komm schon was flüssig wenn bei den
rollen merkt man dass man was so ein
rundes ding und diese diese gefahren
die haben halt haptik im unterhaltung
ausgefallen ja schon einen zufall ich
habe noch drei ob mein gott wer ist
nicht zu schaffen müssen
naja wenn man so hart sagen was ein
zufall ich habe noch vier teig kugel
übrig dann können wir zwar jetzt noch
die übrigen mantel formen und ihr könnt
das rezept gerne ausprobieren
okay ich hab dann heute nichts mehr vor
und falls ihr auch ein mann der rezept
habt aus einem anderen land aus russland
aus afghanistan aus egal woher dann
schreibt gerne in die kommentare
und dann probieren wir gerne auch noch
manche spezialitäten von der ganz
schnell raus inzwischen mit andere
nach klar kartoffel vegan kann man sie
auch machen bestimmt ich mich ganz mehr
also viel spaß und nachmachen bis zum
nächsten mal wir machen jetzt fotos sind
ist ein schneller 4000 programmierten
kann sagt was das 8
[Musik]